you have j-rod getting engaged after two
years together and then there's the
bachelor we thought it was over after
Cassie laughs and then Colton jumped
over the fence but here's the big
question could Cassie come back would
she come back part 1 of the bachelor
finale is two nights well I'm not a
former bachelor okay Becca yeah she
definitely made the leap for love when
she got engaged to Garrett and now the
duo are jumping for joy literally
another reason and our Lord Zima was
there hmm you're going skydiving
together who's more nervous I'm just
nervous that I make peanuts a little bit
so where are we at is there any type of
wedding plan right now no no wedding
plans that's what everyone asks you you
have a timeline are you looking spring
fall next year new year after we've
talked about fall time
Becca and Garrett say they've been
together 24/7 since they got engaged ten
months ago even though his home base was
in Nevada and hers was in Minnesota they
finally moved in together a month ago
and confess they're happy being away
from the cameras and letting Colton take
center stage who do you guys want Colton
Apeco
I don't know I mean we gotta watch the
show first all right guys you can hear
the planes overhead how we feeling any
fear any anticipation what's going
through my mix I just want to get up
there I'm excited too I'm still falling
for you oh wow easy
when you scared it off no not really but
then it all happened so quick that
you're like if I die I die
[Music]